will it is fantastic to see you here at
learned in film on comic-con today what
do you enjoy particularly about this
event about this event well it's lovely
to meet everyone because they're
wonderful they're so nice and also to
hang out with some of the the great game
of Thrones cast because on setting up
such a big class and the whole different
locations mean that you only see quite a
small group of them at any one time so
it's lovely to see the ones that you
don't necessarily crossover with nominee
of course you've been working with Pedro
Pascal and Indu ROM particularly in
season 4 weren't new fantastic both
those actors tell me a little bit about
what it's like working with them welcome
with them the thing I have to say is how
incredibly welcoming they were I mean I
know it Pedro was new to this season but
I always felt I was a bit of a kindred
spirit really you know sort of both of
us being starting and then obviously
he's this major a major character and
was fantastic absolutely amazing he was
a very generous actor and very someone
really great to work opposite to work
off but but more than anything he was
very lovely I mean I mean so friendly
and so open there it was it was really
great and then the same with Finn you
know and in the year before and we spent
a lot of time together and and it made
what could have been quite quite
daunting you know and obviously being to
my first big thing on a show that I
loved and loved before and about getting
naked you know it could have been really
daunting but actually because they were
both so great so professional and so
lovely it made it so easy and just
enjoyed
I mean they look very natural those kind
of intimate scenes on screen with other
with you and fear know whether the with
you and petawatts Callen Indira but I'm
guessing as you say they're quiet it can
be quite awkward I mean what's it like
when you're shooting something like that
it's it's funny I think there's always
that awkwardness at the beginning when
you're especially if you're with someone
new and you're sort of like this could
ultimately I mean it's the actors job to
sort of find that that intimacy and find
that connection but but a lot of actors
especially on this show they have a way
of of becoming close very quickly and
that especially with these kind of
scenes helps because you need that
because it's a it is it's a daunting
thing and if some things aren't right it
can be a very kind of scary thing but
that was never the case never the case
on this show and it's I mean it's also
because I'm so like we love the show so
it continues to get better and better
doesn't it and even when it's utterly
shocking and you're screaming no like we
were with the mountain and Viper tell me
what was it like when you're watching
that scene so I I was I knew it was
going to happen because I I can't resist
when I'm on set so the guy so tell me
about this what's gonna happen with this
when it happened I kind of was the same
with the red weddings I knew the same I
was like like like that because you kind
of go I can't picture it in my head
because somehow Game of Thrones manages
to to make it even more shocking and you
imagine it's going to be and that's kind
of all testament how good it is then it
still managed to shop even when you know
the storylines even know you know about
it's still visually stunning and it was
it was gross wasn't it it's really gross
when the eyes oh my god yeah yeah yeah
that's that was Oh God I kind of feel
like it's only gonna get more and
or like that in the show which which the
fans love it though fans love it I love
it I want to see more of that kind of
thing and Joffrey popped his clogs the
Caesars well Denis what was your
reaction when you saw the king for this
aye I did know what's gonna happen but I
kind of blocks it from my head because I
think Jax character is is amazing and
and he's brilliant doing it and I didn't
actually get to meet Jack but his um the
bin I I saw when I saw him on set I sort
of did a tour of the set and I saw him
the sweetest guy ever all everyone would
say how lovely he was and so it's a
shame it was ashamed that he was gone
from the series but it was a great way
to go it was a great way to go and yeah
that was that was definitely oh my god
scene that was one of those once which I
had my hands covering my face a great
character who also had it oh my god
saying was Tywin wasn't here when he
went on the loo that was it was amazing
I mean it's it's amazing how this show
can consistently keep people not keep
people watching because it's bound to
you know being the the the quality of
the actors in there and the story isn't
that costumes and everything but that it
can consistently make people talk about
it and keep being in the press which is
just shows how how widely viewed it is
and how widely people love it and that's
you know it's just fantastic and we
talked about some people who died this
season but what do you think the kind of
qualities you need to stay alive or in
Game of Thrones and do you think all of
us got what it takes
well I I kind of heard this and now I
kind of believe it but to be true you
are nice in anyway very quickly so I
think I think I think he's manipulative
enough that he'll he might be okay for a
bit I mean I don't actually know I've
not seen this group yet and being an on
book character I can't you know look up
and find out I think he's okay at the
moment but I think a little bit of a spy
as well as working the brothel I think
he knows how to you know to to fend fend
off people and deal with people there we
know you back the season 5 though aren't
you what would you like if you could say
anything that would happen to oliver
carte blanche what do you like to see
happen oh this is good this is a good
question i think i would like to see him
I'd like to see him I know I know
aaden's KarenT has gone off now but it
would be nice to see them sort of join
back together that would be really cool
to see him sort of have a bit of more of
a political role and in in in King's
Landing and to do with with the battle
for the throne I think it would be
really fascinating just to kind of see
see where that led you know because I
feel he's he has ambition he's a very
ambitious character and I think this
could happen but I will say on top of
that that would be great sort of to meet
the dragons he wants the Dragons wants
the dragon really bad no I want to will
once on its all have dragons campaign
might build to buy one here actually you
probably could to be fair I'm a bit of
genetic manipulation
I want to talk about Littlefinger as
well he mentioned it you know like to
maybe spend some more time ice cream
with him he great to see you with more
wood aid as far as such a fantastic
character I mean what do you think his
game plan is at the end of the day
because he's such a sneaky character I
mean it's each each time we see him it a
little bit more gets revealed isn't for
Littlefinger
well this is interesting he he does keep
it to himself quite a lot doesn't he
he's some and it's the same with virus
as well as sort of like um it's a very
good question I think I think he has
sight set very high and I mean it would
be lovely to see Oliver sort of take a
bit of porn in that you know more I mean
the stuff that's happening in the area
is all very exciting
so yeah I see I can't I don't know I
can't really say it's it's it's exciting
well it's an absolute pleasure talking
to you thanks so much for your time
thank you very much
you